[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i'm going
to explain an american superhero comedy
film called zoom
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
thirty years ago a team of five
superheroes called the zenith fought
interstellar criminals and saved the
earth the team leader was a superhero
named zoom he was an ordinary man before
being recruited by the u.s government
for a special program he had the ability
to run faster than the flash the team
also consisted of zoom's elder brother
concussion who was just as good as him
when the earth was at risk of being
invaded the american military led by
general larabee sought to enhance the
team's powers using an experimental form
of radiation called gamma 13. the group
was blasted with the ray which made zoom
faster and stronger but created a
psychotic break in concussion it made
him angry unreasonable and evil
believing that zoom in the team betrayed
him concussion killed three of his
teammates in the end zoom defeated him
and threw him into an interdimensional
portal never to return
however over the years after that zoom
lost his powers slowly and returned to
his old life as jack a mechanic living
in california now after 30 years a
scientist on the zenith project dr grant
finds out that concussion who had
entered a dimensional rift is on a
return trajectory he has not died or
even aged because of his speed through
space-time the scientists have all
reasons to believe that he is just as
powerful and is returning to take
revenge on his brother however zoom has
become accustomed to his life as jack
and has long since lost his powers
because of this general larabee wants to
recruit children with special powers and
train them to fight concussion when he
returns however they only have 12 days
to do so before his arrival the only
person fit to train the special children
is zoom himself the general is sure that
he will not cooperate so he orders grant
to bring him to the base one way or
another then we see the former superhero
captain zoom for the first time since
being retired he is known simply as jack
he uses whatever power he has left to
froth his coffee with his fingers grant
and a psychologist on the zenith project
dr marcia come to recruit jack for the
mission jack thinks the idea is crazy
because they do not need another set of
superheroes sensing that he doesn't want
to be a part of the mission grant shoots
him with a tranquilizer gun and knocks
him out the general and grant have
decided to keep the return of concussion
a secret from jack because they believe
it will make him emotional and fog his
critical thinking then we are introduced
to the youngest member of the team of
superheroes who are yet to be recruited
she is a six-year-old girl named cindy
who has superhuman strength she can pick
up and throw a grown person with no
effort cindy has been using her power to
fight bullies but now wants to audition
to be in the superhero team next is a 16
year old high schooler named summer she
has the power of psychokinesis and can
move a person or an object using just
her mind she can also read people's
minds to some extent because summer is
always alone at school she is considered
an outcast by many hence to try to fit
in she wants to audition for the
superhero team then there is 17 year old
dylan who can become invisible at will
he uses the power to outsmart his
teachers but always gets in trouble
lastly 12 year old tucker has the most
unique power he can blow up the size of
any part of his body and make himself
giant in the training base jack gains
consciousness and is told that he will
be given half a million dollars if he
agrees to train the newbies but if he
declines he will be sent to prison under
a false accusation jack accepts the
offer but he still insists that the
world doesn't need superheroes anymore
following that he officially meets dr
marsha who is his biggest fan she
collects the first edition of all zenith
comics and is obsessed with zoom jack
sees the candidates for the next team of
superheroes and is shocked that they are
all kids he jokingly asks if they're
auditioning for the spelling bee but
grant claims that all the kids who are
participating have been given unique
powers at birth according to dr marsha
they will have to naturally enhance the
children's power because the risk with
gamma 13 is too high the kids show their
special talent some blink too fast while
others are farting machines by the end
of the day cindy summer dylan and tucker
are selected to be trained meanwhile
concussion will be on earth in nine more
days the general and grant are delighted
that they were able to recruit the best
children in such a short period but they
are skeptical as to whether jack will be
able to train them in time the general
is ready to dose the kids with gamma 13
without considering the effect it will
have on their health at first the
recruited children do not take jack
seriously and think that he is just a
random old dude but then dr marsha gives
them a lesson on the history of team
zenith and reveals that jack is actually
captain zoom the youngest two kids start
to look up to him but the oldest dylan
is still skeptical the scientists
including jack check the extent of the
children's powers by making them use
their respective abilities cindy is
always dressed in pretty pink dresses
even while carrying tons of weight jack
finds her annoying but the little girl
talks to him every chance she gets dylan
on the other hand is the most
troublesome of them all he disappears
while they try to evaluate his powers
the facility develops a new alert called
code dylan just to catch him one day
after evaluation jack asks dr marcia
what they're training the kids for but
she dismisses him the truth is that even
she doesn't know about concussions
return in a meeting with the general and
other officials from the military she
presents the results of their last few
evaluations it is revealed that the
children are capable of channeling an
unfathomable amount of energy but
currently they are subconsciously
suppressing their full abilities jack
tries to enter the meeting but is
escorted out by security the following
day grant takes the kids and jack to a
lab where they meet mr pebb an ai robot
that was built to keep team zenith
company with pebb's help jack takes the
children to a room where their old space
saucer is capped he secretly loads the
kids up in the flying vehicle and takes
them out for a ride they fly to wendy's
drive-through and get themselves lunch
everything goes well but the event makes
the news and people start to believe
that the earth is being invaded by ice
cream eating aliens the scientists at
the base find out about jack's little
trip but they can take no action against
captain zoom himself
that night jack is woken up by little
cindy in a rabbit costume
she had a bad dream and wants to sleep
in jack's room for the rest of the night
he feels bad for the little girl and
allows her to sleep on the couch bolted
to the wall cindy thanks him and pulls
the couch out with little to no effort
the following day the scientists put the
kids in a room filled with hundreds of
paintball launchers to train them to
dodge bullets after that they train on
treadmills and use their powers on a
one-on-one session with jack although
they are getting better at using their
specific strengths they still have a lot
to improve on by the end of the day they
are covered in paint and bruises and are
exhausted dylan comments that no one in
the camp cares about them and jack is
only using them for money when cindy
asks him if that is true he neither
confirms nor denies the claim later jack
goes to meet dylan in a cell where he is
being kept for trying to escape he tells
dylan how he was recruited at a young
age and was made to train with his
brother dylan realizes that concussion
who he knows from the comics is also a
real person and is none other than
jack's older brother jack is visibly
uncomfortable talking about him so he
asks grant to let them both out of the
cell in the next one-on-one session with
dylan jack realizes that he may have an
additional special power he asks dylan
to close his eyes and visualize where
summer is right now as the boy focuses
he can see her dancing in her room it
turns out that the power is called super
stalker i mean mind sight and is the
rarest power a human being can have jack
praises dylan for channeling it at such
a young age and declares him the leader
of the team later we see jack and dr
marcia talking together about the
training jack compliments her hard work
which makes her blush she has always
liked and idolized him which he thinks
is adorable in the next scene grant and
the general are at the location where
the portal to another dimension lies
they assume that concussion is going to
emerge in this location and hence make
their soldiers guard the place grant
plans to use the kids as a distraction
and utilize a sonic net to catch
concussion the net will force him to
concuss and hence will turn him back to
normal in an instant when only 48 hours
are left until his arrival jack throws a
party for the kids since they have
worked hard for the past few days dylan
and summer danced together while the
others watched them soon marcia and jack
also joined them however their fun is
ruined when grant interrupts and orders
them to shut down the party immediately
jack sees the soldiers bringing in
equipment for the gamma 13 inducing
process he registers that they are about
to hurt the kids like they hurt his team
30 years ago he retaliates to the
general but the man is adamant about his
decision at midnight jack goes up to the
children's room and wakes them up he
plans to secretly make them run away
before the general can hurt them they
are brought to an electric vent which
leads to a secret room there the kids
finally get their superhero names dylan
is mega boy summer is wonder tucker is
houdini and cindy his princess
suddenly dylan gets a vision from the
other room he learns that the real
mission that officials are working on is
to eliminate concussion when he returns
to the earth when jack finds out that
his brother is alive he almost doesn't
believe him after asking the kids to
remain safe he runs to find out the
truth the general confirms that
concussion is in fact alive and will be
back in less than two hours jack insists
that the kids will never be able to go
up against concussion and urges the
general to abort the mission but he is
locked in a cell so that the project
will run smoothly somewhere else marsha
has found the kids and is bringing them
to grant on her way she blows the guards
away with her rainbow breath revealing
that she also has superpowers then the
group gets jack out of the cell and
flies away in the space saucer at the
same time the dimensional portal opens
and concussion is about to land on earth
the saucer reaches the location jack
asks the kids to stay inside and goes
out to meet his brother they come face
to face and almost do not recognize each
other concussion hasn't aged a day since
they last met while jack has become old
and weak he tries to calm his evil
brother down but concussion pushes him
with an extraordinary force and sends
him flying then the kids who have now
completely turned into superheroes
arrive at the scene only to be made fun
of by concussion when he is distracted
the general launches the web that is
supposed to catch him but concussion
easily diverts its direction towards
cindy as she is about to get hit jack
regains his powers and saves her in a
second following that he runs to the lab
puts on his protective gear and returns
to the location all in less than five
seconds the zenith team is told that if
concussion is placed in the middle of
the web that was thrown earlier there is
a high chance he will turn back to his
normal self dylan uses his power to
distract concussion while summer
launches several rocks at him then
tucker using his bloated stomach throws
him into the air and cindy hits him with
a pole at last marcia uses her breath to
push him into the web in only a few
seconds concussion returns back to his
normal self and stops being aggressive
zoom asks dr grant to come with them and
forms a new zenith team consisting of
himself marsha dr grant concussion dylan
summer tucker and cindy in the final
scene we see them flying away in a
saucer subscribe for more videos like
this turn on notifications and leave a
like to help the channel out thank you
for watching